the university of kentucky swimmer riley
gaines has been
speaking out
about this according to daily wire by
the way speaking out about university of
pennsylvania swimmer leah thomas a
biological male
and stated that when the college women
competed against thomas at the ncaa
uh championships they were not
forewarned that thomas would be sharing
the locker room with them and undressing
in front of them so gaines spoke with
tucker carlson
um and was talking about
first just the atmosphere fear at the
championships
which it happened at georgia tech a
couple of months ago she said um
she said people just weren't talking
about it and so we get to the ncaas
and it was at georgia tech and so we get
there and the environment is nothing
like i've ever seen before it was so
almost edgy like people didn't really
know what to say who to say what to or
how to feel
and from here we'll go to the clip where
she tells the the rest of the story what
happened at the event and especially in
the locker room so let's listen to
that and then that night we watched leah
thomas win a national title and blow all
the other females completely out of the
water
and that next day we came back and the
mood had shifted to where people were
mad
the girls you know there were tears um
these poor 9th and 17th place finishers
who missed out on being named an
all-american um there's extreme
discomfort in the locker room there's
you know kind of these
grumbles is he wandering around the
women's locker room
yeah when and that's not something you
know we were forewarned about which i
don't think is right in any means um
changing in a locker room with someone
who has different
parts
so they just set a dude loose in your
locker room and didn't tell you exactly
and so i feel like to have that kind of
forced upon us so not only were we you
know forced to race against a male we
were forced to to change in the locker
room with one
and so
it's just this feeling of like
what is happening like honestly like
is this really happening like this is
crazy
uh
so there's a story that she tells it
there and again that's uh riley gaines
who
should be commended first of all for her
courage and speaking out about this
and the story she tells about the locker
room that to me is by far
the the bigger scandal
um the the more important aspect of this
whole story of of of leah thomas and men
in general invading women's sports um
the fact that they're forced into the
pool with with a man and and the man is
stealing
medals and opportunities and all that
that of course is terrible and insane
but even worse is that they're made to
share the locker room
with the guy
just having their privacy
and their dignity
really taken from them
and yet that very often is treated like
um
you know
like not not as much of a concern as
what's happening in the pool what's
happening with with sports
and that's one thing that stuck with me
i thought was interesting when in uh my
film was a woman when we talked to
one of leah thomas's teammates
and i asked her about the locker room
situation it was the same kind of thing
yeah thomas is in the locker room he's
getting changed and
same thing she said there's like no
conversation about it no discussion
about that
even when they brought in when uh when
university pennsylvania brought in the
lgbt activists and counselors to lecture
the women
and tell them that hey if you've got a
problem with this you you need to go
seek counseling no the guy who's
claiming to be a woman
and you know wearing the one-piece
bathing suit he doesn't need to see a
council you do if you have an issue with
it
but even then
the the locker room part of it wasn't
even talked about
she said in fact that um
you know the other women on the team
most of them didn't want to say anything
at all because they were afraid of the
backlash
but even the women who did speak out
uh they they were focused on the sport
part of it and not the locker rooms
which i just thought was was interesting
there's another point i want to make too
which is when you hear a story like this
these men going to women's locker rooms
we talk about it so much
but you very often hear from people on
the right
that hey
you know what the women who are who are
subjected to this it's up to them to
speak out and if they're not going to
speak out then i'm washing my hands of
it there's nothing i can do
you know sort of putting the onus on the
women on the girls who are in these
situations
to say something about it and i agree
that we do need to call on everyone to
have courage and the closer you are to a
situation like this
the more of a responsibility you have to
speak out
but it just seems really cowardly to me
on the part of some conservatives to say
i'm not going to say anything about it
the women aren't pro this is on them
especially as a man
right if you're a man you should be
you should have a drive to protect women
like to put it on a bunch of college
girls
to stand up against the guys that are
going into the locker rooms
what kind of man are you
is that would that be your attitude if
you were actually in a place and uh you
saw a man about to walk into a
there was a man about to walk into a
woman's locker room would you say well
that's up to the women in there to
figure it out not me
but if your daughter your wife is in
there would you say well they're gonna
have to they gotta stand up for
themselves
i certainly hope not i hope you would
realize that it's your responsibility as
a man to step up
yes men should protect women i
understand that that is
um
considered an outmoded way of thinking
but i don't care
that's the reality it's the truth
so no i'm not just i'm not just going to
leave it to
girls in college and in high school to
be the ones to fight this thing out
[Music]
oh they don't do it then nothing i can
do
that to me is a lame excuse
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated